so a very good morning good afternoon or
good evening to wherever you are
wherever you may be
all right so today we are gonna go for
6400 series uh agilent lc uh triple quad
webinar right
my name is calvin and i'm one of the
trainers from agilent university
for this product line
and we're going to have a overlooked
overview
maintenance tips covered over this about
45 minutes all right
right beside me you can see here um i
have a 64 70 a series model
over this course of this
short webinar i'll be introducing to you
this 6470 as i will be having a look at
the internal of a 6460
here an
o6460 right so without further ado um
let's get to the objectives so we're
going to have a look at a recognition of
the instrument that you may have in your
lab or you may be intending uh budgeting
to purchase for your use
this instrument
is used in many areas
ranging from food safety pesticides
analysis
to even plasma signals analysis to even
so-called research r d in the academia
so it's important to recognize the
elements of the instrument as well as to
have a look at the workstation pc
software applications
before we go for the general usage and
maintenance tips
so over here in this slide you will be
able to see that um we will have the
range stuff on starting from the 6420
6430 right and uh 6460
6470 which is a general work cost in
most labs nowadays so the 64.95 which is
the most sensitive uh in the market
um it's more sensitive because of the
iphone technology that's present in this
product
right
and in this slide you will be able to
see the
specifications
um
as you would have seen the 6495b
right is the uh most sensitive in a
sense having a signal to noise of 150
000 is to one there is a injection of
one picogram of recipient on to the
using the mrn mode
um but the
6495c which is now in the market there
is a further enhancement to that to
close to about 550 000 is the one
and uh if we are going to look at the
6470 right 70 a and now is the 70 b
right 70 b we are now having a
sensitivity level of about 350 000 this
to one so there is quite a big
improvement
um
over this slide you also can see that
there are some consumables that you
might need to take note of if you are
using the various kinds of models across
in your laboratory right the capillary
style itself are mainly different
if you take a look at the 6470 we are
still going for a single ball capillary
to the more sensitive 6495 which
requires a hexaball capillary which is
about mycm also in length
um
and in terms of the
collision cell style
right you will be able to see that some
of the product lines are based on a
linear design
while over here you can see the
6470a
it is a more smaller footprint and it is
basically on a curved collision cell
design right you'll be able to see the
schematics in the uh next slide
and
of course
what is the mass pack without having a
good vacuum we will need a good working
rough pumps
um some of which you can see that we
have one and uh most of it will be
having a two
right and only by having a good uh
vacuum the ions will be able to be
so-called uh fly through the uh
pole
selected right and reach the detector
so in this slide you will be able to see
the details
regarding the schematics and the design
of the various models of the mass spec
right ranging from the 64 to 30 6470
which is now the curved design
um we'll be having the so-called sample
introduction the liquid will be
dissolvated in the dissolvation assembly
over here you can see the spray chamber
right the nebulizer will be sitting over
right over here
and we'll be having it
you know liquid spraying and of course
because of the ags
right the ajs
technology the jet stream technology
will be having a superheated shaft of
aerosol being spread out over in the
nozzle over here
and of course we'll be having the ions
being sampled through
in the within the um so-called
um ion capillary
going through
right uh we'll be seeing that in the
later part of the demo right of course
we'll be having the capillary and then
the ion optics
all the ions will go through and do the
selecting of the ions itself depending
on the method
right right which is on the software
we'll be uh implementing it on the
quadrupole so we have the ms-1 quad
and then followed through the curved
collision cell
and following the ms2 quad and finally
the detector
so depending on whether you are going
for a scan or you are be looking at more
sensitive analysis you will be
implementing or mrm
multimode reaction monitoring or even
um dmrm you know dynamic right is a
dynamicism in terms of the selection of
the uh window retention time windows
right
um
yeah and then we're having the 95 6495
which incorporates the ifunnel
technology which have two eye funnels
you know one having of a higher to lower
pressure this is to allow ions to be
actually sampled through
yeah and by having a hexable capillary
you will be definitely getting more ions
going through so this places more
a lot of importance
in terms of the regular maintenance
and also the periodic maintenance
all right so we're going to pause here
for a moment to take a look at the 6460
which is of a linear design
welcome back and let's resume
now i'm now just right standing right
beside a 6460a instrument and i
basically open up the spray chamber
itself right you will be able to see
that the nozzle itself on this
instrument
is a bit dark color or even brownish or
dark brownish so this this is a symptom
whereby it's time to really have a goal
at changing the uh the nozzle insulator
itself otherwise you will be affecting
your so-called reservation right and the
sensitivity might be
right
um so now right now i'm going to just
remove the spray chamber
the spray shield
from the spray chamber
and you can see that there's a capillary
cap
right we have already kept a little
closer to the uh
yeah
the video itself right so
you can do some fine tuning
um
within the
cap there is in fact a
painted coil gold spring
so the ghost ring also should be in a
good condition typically but if it's
ever found to be uh so-called distorted
yeah um is better time for
replacement right it is a
you know a small gold spring just right
within that
and you can see the
capillary the resistive capillary being
uh yeah this part so we can actually try
to
remove it so all these are done supposed
to be done in a vented stick
right
um however with the new technology from
agilent right uh the instruments without
a vent no full vent
that will be also part of the later part
of this webinar you can take a look at
the video at your own time
right that calls for
really without a full vent and you can
be able to remove the
capillary so this is one of the most
important consumables to use for sample
the ions in the first pass
so right now i'm going to walk over to
show you different parts of the
instrument
um starting from the calibrate delivery
system
right
where we have our two mix in the in this
bottle
and uh the valve is actually diverting
between the um lc to
smash back or even to to waste so this
is working
through this caliber delivery valve or
even drawing the year so called two mix
right
and what you do not see that is right
inside this is across the
table
actually
in there right
we do see the back end of the
pump the five floor pump right here
and i shall
go over and the brown tubing you may be
wondering what this brown tubing is for
so when we are looking at uh running a
tendon called triple quad all right
we'll be having collision gas 2
a pure collision guess true and this is
where the gas is actually going into
your ms2
right and i shall remove the cover so
that we can uh take a further look
right so i have the camera to zoom in on
the various parts
as you can see beyond the dissolvation
chamber which holds the
capillary we have the ion optics
within this window here
see the iron output in fact there are
a lot of octopus
within it
really a close look okay first
as best as we can
right
within it all right so this is the ion
objects
and that's where our ms1 is
so this is the previous design whereby
things are still linear but uh the parts
within it
may be almost similar okay so you have
the ms-1
and you have the collision cell which is
the ms2
and of course we have
on the street
so
msms and of course the detector
so this is the part of the
gcd vector
so this is what picks up the ions and
translate that into the signals
right so we have a good look
so i hope i you have a good look at the
internals of the
6460 um first apologies a bit of
correction in terms of the technology
right so we are having two mass
analyzers so we'll be having actually
ms-1 and ms2 so lc qqq one is called qqq
in this case when we only have uh two
actually two quadruples that are in fact
on the instrument itself because of the
second q is actually part of the uh so
called the collision cell that's why
it's called qqq so q1 for the first
quadrupole which is the mass analyzer
and these samples in the uh mass ions
depending on the methods that you set
with a scan or plus you're looking at an
mrn which is a specific ion
right and then uh we have the second q
which is the collision cell right the
collision cell itself is where the
influx of the so-called the gas
collision gas flow will be going into
the collision cell
and that's where the dissociation of the
so-called first ions the first ions that
are selected you know it's going to
happen
and the so-called the last uh or the
second the mass analyzer itself which is
the q3 right so this is the one that is
going to be another specific selection
um therefore when you have multiples of
this kind of so-called reaction
monitoring we determine mrms
all right so i guess that's enough
what's in the terminology right
um in terms of the iron sources that are
supported on on this series of the lcms
right we have the latest which is jet
stream
so the jet stream are available on the
6470 and also the 64
95
and of course we have the so-called
typical the traditional esi
this is the most basic and we have the
apci
a multi-mode which allows you to do the
esi and apci at the same time
right
um on the qqq analyzer so these are the
various parts that we have seen on the
linear the linear design 6064 60 you
have the iron optic region whereby your
fossil capillary will stand before the
ions
and the schema which is samples the uh
ion b
and we have the octopus
right so we by applying uh so-called
correct rf right it terminalizes the the
ion beam itself and really focuses it
right
and we have the lens 1 and the lens 2
the rf this enhances the high mass ions
transmission
because we'll be looking at masses over
wide range right depending on on your
application itself
so we cannot disregard the uh the high
mass ions transmission right
um then of course the orange region you
have the five six and seven
um first the vacuum itself is supported
by the adwords turbo pump um we have
seen that in the earlier demo which is
just sitting right beside
the squat
right so the ms1 basically filter the
digital cell as i mentioned this is a
high pressure hexapole
yeah whereby your high prt n2 your
nitrogen gas is funneled in
and of course we have the last part
which is the detector which emphasizes
and multiplies the
so-called ions
right to get our signal
um you also have seen the so-called
single ball resistive capillary earlier
on
and the the latest part uh the latest
capillary that we have on the on the
6495 for example is the hexa ball it's
about half the length of the uh
resistive capillary
right but there are six holes six six
holes on on this hexa ball itself
um
you can see the basically the v cap the
capillary itself
v chamber
and you might be interested to take a
look at the the video of the vex shield
technology which is technology that i
mentioned earlier on so this allows us
to do some maintenance or even the
replacement
of this uh capillary and it's applicable
on the altivo which is uh really a small
nice footprint lc triple quad and the
6470b
as well as 495p
and now the c model right
and the
lc single quote iq
every module in an lcms system requires
occasional maintenance
but when that maintenance is needed it
should be easy not complicated and fast
to ensure the lcms returns to full
operation
this innovation minute will describe how
vat shield ensures maximum uptime for
the altivo triple quad lcms
fact shield allows the ion source cap
layer to be removed and installed
without venting the mass spectrometer
fact shield has no handles or actuators
and is small enough to fit into the
desalination chamber without increasing
the size of the ms
here's how this innovation works
in order to withdraw the capillary a
special gripper is employed since the
tube can be extremely hot
as the capillary is withdrawn it passes
a seal that allows the vacuum within the
instrument's manifold to enter the vac
shield valve
further withdrawing the capillary allows
differential pressure to seal the void
left by the tube by a two small valve
elements
with the capillary removed that shield
still allows a little air to leak into
the manifold
this small leak is intentional and
important since it prevents back
streaming of contaminants from the rough
pump into the vacuum manifold
when reinserting the capillary the
process is simply reversed
with vaxshield maintenance is very fast
and very simple
to learn more about other innovations in
the el tivo triple quad lcms please
visit agilent's website
so
what we have um in this slide shows the
uh previously 6495 b
right without the new effect shoe
technology this is the one that still
requires a gate valve but basically the
idea is
to so-called isolate right so without
really fully venting the uh mass fat so
this allows a quicker you know uptime of
the instrument after basically a
replacement of the capillary or even a
cleaning test
so this is the iron optics which
incorporates both the schema which
really focuses the beam and the flex of
the neutrals
and the octopole itself
and the
enhancement or the increment in the
sensitivity for the 64.95
is due to the presence of these two you
know pressure uh funnels or one which is
the first high pressure funnel so this
allows really uh
very much more ions to be going through
before really going through a low
pressure funnel
and then finally to the q1 or the first
ms
analyzer
how does this ion funnel work
itself if we have the rf voltage which
focuses the ions to the sensor
right and we have the dc voltage which
accelerates the ions basically to the
exit point right which is basically h2
to the quad itself
all right so more about the uh the ir
optics
design of that
and the
control one which is your ms-1 without
the hyperbolic rods
right the hexapole rod
on the collision cell
or the q2 all right
and you have only 64 17 95 you have a
larger entrance aperture and a smaller
you know accident so this basically will
focus
you know further focus the ions into
your second analyzer which is the ms2
yeah and finally of course the q3 which
is the
ms2
and last but not least the detectors
which have the high energy dyno which
basically you can study in positive or
even in negative mode to look at
ions
and of course the resources okay most
important the resources for users and
where can we find them so for every new
installation um we do have this
so-called resources uh umd or the time
drive itself where they can get it to be
installed onto your desktop um for easy
access to the uh e-flamerization or
electronic memorization and further look
at other available resources like even
the videos or even some basic manuals or
quick start guides
okay so after the
so-called resources is being installed
onto the desktop you will get a shortcut
um which has a really a small blue book
so i'm going to open up the one that i
have on my desktop
and this is where you can see the
various resources
that are available to a user
right you do get one resource on the
data acquisition so you do get a quick
start guide
right
and in terms of the mass pack itself you
do get maintenance guide which is really
animated
and you also get an ephemeralization
guide for acquisition this will act as a
quick start for users new users
especially so right now i'm just gonna
have a very short you know we look at
the maintenance guide
and you can see that
once i click on browse
there is an over view um you do get some
info regarding the startup and shutdown
i guess which is really important these
days
right
and you can take a look at this
and
you can see that for example the ion
transfer capillaries
how to remove the capillary
guides for that what you
need right uh in terms of uh
disinfection perhaps
right
okay so these are really very good
resources for users to have on their
site for a quick reference
all right so if we take a look at the
nebulizer itself
perhaps how to
adjust or replace the needle
um you can see that there are some
information other than the tools needed
right a picture of that
glass
the
images of the uh lock nut
right
and also
quick video on on this
so it's really a nice resource to have
uh
you know
on your pc itself
so that uh if you need reference right
you can come here to have a look
just going to show this for another
10 seconds yep
hey
i hope you have a good look at the
animated maintenance guide yeah
it's a good resource to have
um
so in terms of the data acquisition
we're using the mass hunter to control
um to do our tuning
uh to be in the tuning context so that
we can perform um check tunes or even
manual tunes
right but most of the time when you run
into issues you will perhaps want to
fall back on a full auto tune
in either the positive or the negative
mode depending on the application that
you are working with
and that's where we can also through the
masseter acquisition perform our you
know our work list setup
and uh edit our method
to do a scan or maybe a dmrm
right that's where we we can you know
set up and optimize our parameters
manually
um we do have the qualitative analysis
this allows us to have a quick look uh
through you know finding uh
the compounds itself through the mrm
algorithm right which is one of the
common uses
and the quant itself will allow us to
fall back on the reporting side to
really
provide a report to user like yourself
you know to
not only to integrate analyze but to
really have a figure and a look at the
amount
uh whether it's in terms of
concentration or amount
right of the component that you are
interested in or you're targeted at so
take note that this is a targeted
analysis
instrument yeah targeted
approach
therefore as you can see
most of the times we might be injecting
quite dirty samples in there right um
it's good to have a sample prep prior or
at least uh do some kind of sonication
uh
yeah and then do the supernatant
extraction or solvent extraction
yeah um this
this uh emphasize that uh the pm is
important and this can be scheduled
every six months spaces or on really
annual basis depending on your use and
your needs
right
and we have a pm list for that
um
proper mobile phase preparation is
important for any kind of lcms use
so ranging from single quad all the way
up to end to term of flight right so
this is to ensure that not only we try
to eliminate or reduce the contamination
or even the ion suppression matters
this will allow us to have you know
ensure that we have a good sensitivity
and performance for the instrument
right
so we always try to use
mass spec great water from the uh from
the system
right
always use the
ms grid solvents of very clean solvents
by the smallest volume of the
additives of reagents or the other
modifiers
and we replace the buffer starting
materials at least
every year so this is ensures that you
can have a fresh you know buffer sort to
for preparation
this is some quick note that's found on
the lcgc uh forum um it's about the
stability of formic acid in methanol
itself
so this through this uh note itself or
this
article uh it does conclude that blends
of formic acid and methanol right added
together with
in water of course
can actually affect the stability yeah
so this will affect your some of your
applications that are out there in the
market right
so the important takeaway is to prepare
everything fresh
in terms of the lc it is also a very
important component because that's where
our sample introduction is
right and that is where also the
so-called solvents are being pumped
through the system
um you try to limit the
unstability of through the pressure
itself
you should have a very good stable
baseline and that is
from the so-called pump right
performance itself
to having a good performing pump
and
we should actually take a look at also
the solvent inlet filters that are on
the uh in the bottles itself
um faster the gesso
uh perform the pump maintenance either
on a you know half yearly or even a
yearly basis
auto sampler in terms of getting good
reproducibility
and getting good uh so-called linear
regression line
and it's very important when you're
doing calibration that
when you're injecting one micro liter is
really one microliter right
um and of course the maintenance of the
detector is stopped um which is the mass
spec in this case
so a very general uh
pm on the
typical general llc um you really think
about four hours or so
in the next slide you are able to see
right on the on the left hand side right
um
effects you know build up of buffer
socks in the spray chamber itself so
this should be a daily clinic process
by any user of lcms
right typically with 50 50 of
ipa or even methanol water so give it a
good nice clean wipe
so that uh you do not have any issues
later on right
uh
some pictures of the cleaning process
itself and also
cross contamination which should be
cleaned off
and various pictures about the different
so-called
spray shoe and the
end cap
and the caterpillar which you have seen
earlier on through the video demo
and we do need to check the depth of the
needle of the nebulizer it is a very
important uh portion
so that it will spray can be of a
so-called good order
yeah so this this can be actually
enhanced by adjusting with the toolkit
that uh agent
provides to users to new users on a new
system itself
and other operating tips are like vacuum
levels which you should monitor
because if the the pumps are so-called
failing your vacuum will be affected and
that will definitely impact on your
performance of the amount of ions that
it's going through
right um then we need to check the rough
form oil
make sure that the pump doesn't run dry
check tune as much as you need it could
be on a daily weekly basis depending on
the sop
auto tune is on the other hand
infrequent
because usually we do it when we are
facing some issues or we hope that the
other two can help you to overcome
otherwise it really means that we really
have to focus on the maintenance of the
system
or cleaning of the internal parts it's
beyond the capillary right
when changing sources of course you do
have to put the instrument to standby
mode right um
not only changing sources even let's say
for example if you have a
tq with
let's say you're going to change the ion
capillary or even clean the iron library
and you do have a gate valve and you do
have to use the gate valve wow the
capillary and before all this happens
the system has to be in a standby mode
this is to so-called bring down the
temperature to a much lower level you
can handle right the internals because
it's hot
right when you open up the spray chamber
you know it feels not only warm it's hot
right you do not want to really
you have to put safety as first
and the next thing is that you have to
shut down the electronics
so if you would like to know more about
agent university we do have different uh
kinds of education styles that may suit
your training needs
we do have the standard classroom
trainings
we also do have the virtual instructor
lab training so these are very basically
very short you know just lecture style
only that means through the slides
and also availability of self-paced
e-learning
courses are through subscription so this
could be a half yearly subscription
basis or even a yearly subscription
basis so if you would like to know more
so please visit our website
and we do also have the course calendar
out there for you to
download
right so this is a qr code
if you are interested to know more about
the calendar and more information you
can scan the qr code
and
typically for the
mass spec courses
we do have these causes uh
some of it that ends off with c so these
are full-fledged uh causes um classroom
style basis
and the v ends also with v for example
the two two seven four v so that's a
virtual course
right so there's a virtual plus
thank you for your attention and your
questions please feel free to leave them
and i'll try to answer as much as i can
thank you to calvin for that very
insightful presentation
we'll now proceed to the question and
answer section uh we have a few
questions in the box but please do feel
free to put together a question very
insightful presentation so kevin the
first question is are there any
databases for the lc triple quad
applications
if um let me mute myself i hope that you
can hear me clearly
yes thank you that's good yes uh i think
that there might be a thinking that uh
for lc tripcot since there is going to
be more targeted analysis um a lot of
times uh it will be more uh through
manual optimization
or even through using our optimizer
software which is pretty good
um however agilent does offer databases
for certain applications for example in
the forensics field or in the toxicology
area so these are actually triggered
mrms so-called database
and if you are working with
environmental or we do have the water
screening
and uh pfas mrm databases
um and in terms of the food safety right
we do have also things like the
veterinary drug triggered mrn databases
to support your work so that it can get
you up to speed
and if you do work in the metabolomics
research area we do have also the dmrm
databases
if you have any interest uh we are we
are much happy to share this with you in
terms of the product number
right
right
thank you
um we have a second question
given that the g6495c
is selling now
what are the key advantages as compared
to the b or a series
right uh this is a very interesting one
um because if you have seen it through
the video itself um we do now have the
mac shield feature
so this allows you as a user to you
really work with the system uh in terms
of the maintenance um for example if you
do really need a journey to replace the
iron transfer capillary um you do have
the availability of the automatic valve
shut off
and this can provide you with a
so-called vent free
quite rapid uh maintenance process um
other than that um if you do notice that
previously
most of the triple quartz would come
with two times ms-40
rough pumps so these rock pumps
basically will work up to about you know
40 meters cube per hour of the in terms
of the palm rate capacity
um but now with the 6495c
it is replaced with just a single ms 120
roping pump
um the other key advantage is that it
does reduce the in terms of the gas flow
turbulence
and will probably improve the
percent rsd in terms of the
reproducibility of your results
especially if you are working with
really low deal times
most of the times we'll be looking at uh
probably
five millisecond or even sometimes if
you have a lot of cycles to to look at
it could be
one or even a point five four
milliseconds a time
so these are the times whereby uh having
a good stable vacuum
you know especially the initial vacuum
would help in terms of your rsd
and uh the last point i wish to share is
that with the 6495c
this would expand your mass range to up
to about 3000 m by z
and you'll be definitely useful for
targeting a hive molecular weight
peptides
that are actually multiple charged
right
so right i guess yeah
thank you thank you um we have one more
final question actually in the q a um
can you elaborate on the stability of
formic acid in methanol
sure sure
so i can repeat again this article can
be found on the lcgc forum which you can
uh just google online easily um the
article volume is 26
number nine
september of 2008
right we can also share the path with
you if you leave us with your details
um in a nutshell this study basically
show whenever we have a
so-called acid and also alcohol in the
presence of atmosphere there could be
chances of esterification
and what is found by of course the gcms
um the ester formation
and with the decreasing formic acid so
you would do have a change in terms of
the ph and this could
lead to some shift in retention times
and
this article was basically looking at uh
peptides
of interest
so things like
bradykinin
or even a messiani and keplin and
oxitocin
i i guess well what i really learned
from from this article is that a clear
message is to really prepare our mobile
face fresh when whenever we need
especially we need some kind of buffer
concentration
and also ph
thank you calvin and there are no more
questions in the q a so that will bring
our webinar to a close before we do go
i'd like to remind you all please do
take a look around our virtual symposium
visit our exhibition center and see all
their booths and visit our on-demand
center and see all our breakout sessions
as well and if you've got time please
we'd love to hear from you and fill out
our survey
so once again thank you very much to
calvin for this fantastic presentation
and i wish you all a very nice day thank
you
a pleasure